Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Avant de monter sur cette scène,
je discutais avec quelqu’un du staff
dans les loges.
Je vois sur son badge
qu’elle s’appelle Marion.
Comme moi !
Je me dis que c’est l’occasion
d’en apprendre plus sur elle
et sur son parcours.
Marion m’explique qu’elle est étudiante
en événementiel, qu’elle a 20 ans
et qu’elle est bénévole
sur l’organisation de ce TEDx.
Elle me demande de quoi
va parler ma conférence.
Je lui explique que je dirige un cabinet
de conseil en RSE appelé Rupture engagée
et que j’accompagne les petites
et moyennes entreprises
à mettre en place une démarche RSE.
Je vois par les grands yeux ronds
écarquillés de Marion
que la RSE ne fait pas franchement
partie de son vocabulaire.
Développement durable, peut-être ?
Ça te parle plus ?
Ah oui, là , je vois qu'elle me comprend.
Je lui explique donc que la RSE,
la responsabilité sociétale
de l’entreprise,
c’est tout simplement l’application des
principes du développement durable
dans son activité.
Naturellement, on va parler environnement,
mais aussi impact social,
sociétal et environnemental.
Je demande à Marion si,
sur le plan personnel,
elle fait des choses
dans sa vie quotidienne.
Elle me répond que oui,
elle fait des choses par ci, par là,
pour le recyclage,
pour le tri des déchets,
mais que concrètement, elle ne voit pas
ce qu’elle peut faire de plus
et qu’elle a l’impression
qu’elle est trop petite.
Je ne dis rien.
Je laisse le silence,
je continue à l’écouter.
Tout d’un coup,
elle me dit que de toute façon,
elle ne voit pas vraiment ce que
les petites entreprises pourraient faire,
en quoi elles pourraient
changer quelque chose
aux problématiques que l’on connaît.
Ma chère Marion, laisse-moi te dire
qu’en RSE, personne n’est trop petit.
Aucune entreprise n’est trop petite
pour changer le monde
et aucune personne n’est trop petite
pour changer le monde.
Commençons par les entreprises.
Naturellement, quand on parle de RSE,
on pense spontanément aux grands groupes,
aux grandes entreprises.
Et c’est normal parce que ce sont elles
qui ont les contraintes réglementaires,
qui ont les obligations légales
de faire de la RSE.
Alors, elles communiquent et nous tiennent
au courant de ce qu’elles font.
Ce sont aussi ces grandes entreprises qui
ont des moyens humains et financiers
de mettre en place des actions,
des engagements
et de communiquer sur ces actions.
Et puis, tu sais, Marion, ces grandes
entreprises ne sont pas folles,
elles ont très bien compris l’opportunité
économique que ça représentait,
puisqu’il y a de plus en plus de pression
par les parties prenantes des entreprises
que ce soit les parties prenantes
internes comme les collaborateurs,
ou les parties prenantes externes
comme les clients, les prospects.
Par exemple, en tant que consommateur,
en tant que client,
tu es peut-être comme moi, Marion,
et tu attaches une attention particulière
à l’engagement de la marque
aux conditions de travail,
à l’éthique du produit que tu achètes.
Nous sommes de plus en plus de
consommateurs à comprendre
que ce qui n’est pas cher en euros
l’est certainement sur le plan social
et environnemental.
Et en tant que collaborateur,
en tant que salarié,
on attache là aussi une attention
toute particulière sur les engagements,
sur l’éthique de l’entreprise.
Travailler avec du sens, c'est important.
Ne plus risquer sa santé,
ne plus risquer le burn-out,
c’est important,
et certainement encore plus pour toi,
Marion,
qui rentres bientôt
sur le marché du travail.
Alors, tu vois, Marion en entreprise,
on n’est jamais trop petit pour agir.
Parlons maintenant de toi,
tu es une jeune citoyenne.
Tu as 20 ans.
Et pourtant, je vois que tu as vraiment
l’impression que tu es trop petite.
Et pourtant,
regarde tous ces mouvements citoyens
qui émergent de partout.
Regarde les marches du climat.
Regarde toutes ces alternatives que
l'on trouve dans les magasins.
Pense à toutes ces applications
que l’on peut télécharger sur notre mobile
pour être tenu au courant des engagements
des marques et de leur éthique.
Pense à tous ces tiers lieux, ces
éco-lieux qui se construisent
et qui nous proposent de nouvelles
manières de nous loger et nous rencontrer.
Et tu sais, Marion, pour faire des euros,
il faut faire des heureux.
Et ça, les entreprises l’ont bien compris,
comme cette entreprise
que tu connais peut-être,
qui s’appelle «C’est qui le patron ?»
qui souhaite rémunérer
au juste prix ses producteurs.
Ces entreprises, qui sont de plus en plus
engagées, sont de plus en plus nombreuses.
Moi, tu sais, Marion, j’ai une nouvelle
définition de la RSE.
Plutôt que de parler de responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises,
je te propose autre chose :
le R de Réparer.
Réparer notre écosystème,
réparer notre environnement,
réparer nos erreurs, finalement.
Nous ne sommes plus à l’ère
du développement durable,
mais des réparations durables.
Le S de Sortir :
sortir des idées préconçues,
sortir des a priori que nous avons,
sortir de notre petit confort
et nous diriger vers des modèles
économiques plus engagés et responsables.
Et enfin, le E de Ensemble.
Ce n’est que dans le collectif,
dans le collaboratif
que nous pourrons trouver des solutions.
Et tu sais, ce collectif, il est possible
parce qu’un jour,
une petite personne
ou un petit groupe de personnes
s’est mobilisé et s’est associé.
Marion, aujourd’hui,
tu n’as que 20 ans, tu as peur.
Tu te sens désemparée, tu te poses
plein de questions quant à l’avenir.
Mais tu sais, moi, je n’ai peut-être
que 10 ans de plus que toi
et je suis quand même capable de te dire
que tu n’es pas trop petite.
Tes doutes d’aujourd’hui,
tes révoltes d’aujourd’hui deviendront
ta force et tes engagements de demain.
Alors oui, peut-être que ça fait
depuis toute ta vie
que tu manges de la viande à tous
les repas et des produits industriels,
Mais tu peux tout à fait végétaliser
ton alimentation,
devenir végétarienne petit à petit.
Tu peux tout à fait consommer
local, de saison,
faire appel à des producteurs locaux.
Être végétarienne et en bonne santé,
c’est possible.
Si tu t’inquiètes pour
tes performances au marathon,
ne t’en fais pas, on peut tout à fait
être végétarienne et marathonienne.
Je sais, Marion, que tu adores voyager,
partir en découverte.
Mais tu sais, tu peux très bien réduire
de 90 % tes déplacements en avion
sans pour autant te priver de tout ça.
Et qui sait, peut-être qu’un jour tu
rentreras chez toi à La Rochelle,
depuis la Guadeloupe à la voile,
et que ça deviendra
la plus belle expérience de ta vie.
Marion, je sais que tu es encore étudiante
et que tu cherches encore ta voie
en faisant des stages à droite, à gauche
dans différents secteurs d’activités.
Mais si dans le fond, tu ressens
que tu n’es pas à ta place,
il est encore temps
de réorienter tes études,
de changer de filière
et de te diriger vers un master
en développement durable et RSE.
Et si jamais, malgré tous tes diplômes,
ton premier travail, ton premier CDI
ne t’épanouit pas à 100 %,
alors tu peux très bien changer.
Et si jamais ton deuxième CDI
ne t’épanouit toujours pas,
alors il est peut-être temps d’écouter
ce que te crie vraiment ton cœur
et d’aller au bout de ce
que tu as dans le ventre.
Tu sais, Marion, tout est possible.
Et si ton rêve, c’est de changer le monde
et d’aider les entreprises
à ce qu’elles-mêmes changent le monde
grâce à leur démarche RSE,
alors tu peux le faire.
Ma petite Marion, accroche-toi !
Accroche-toi à tes rêves !
Accroche-toi à tes conviction !
Accroche-toi à tes engagements !
Parce qu’en RSE,
en développement durable,
personne n’est trop petit.
Qui sait, peut être qu’un jour
tu dirigeras une petite entreprise
qui elle-même aidera les petites
entreprises à devenir plus engagées
grâce à leur démarche RSE ?
Parce que tu sais, elles sont nombreuses,
ces PME à vouloir faire des choses
à vouloir aller plus loin.
Alors oui, elles mènent déjà
des actions par ci, par là.
Elles ont déjà des engagements.
Mais elles ont besoin d’aide
pour formaliser leurs engagements,
les structurer et aussi apprendre
à les communiquer, les valoriser,
auprès de leurs parties prenantes.
Et tu sais, Marion,
tu vas rencontrer un sacré paquet
de personnes qui sont très engagées
et qui ont un sacré paquet
d’idées et d’énergie à déployer
au profit des causes qui aujourd’hui
te tiennent à cœur.
Tu n’es pas trop petite, Marion,
parce que tu n’es pas seule
et c’est ce qui te permettra
de faire des grandes choses.
Tu sais, on commence tous débutants.
Et qui sait, peut être que dans 10 ans,
tu te retrouveras sur la scène d’un TEDx,
à faire une conférence devant
des centaines de personnes
et de professionnels pour leur expliquer
qu’ils ont tout le pouvoir
et les capacités nécessaires
à mettre en place des choses
pour changer le monde
et contribuer à un monde meilleur
pour les générations futures.
D’ailleurs, bas les masques !
Vous l’aurez peut-être compris,
cette Marion à qui je m’adresse
depuis tout à l’heure
n’est autre que la Marion Martinez
que j’étais il y a une dizaine d’années.
J’ai longtemps douté que je pouvais avoir
un impact concret et réel
sur l’environnement sur le plan personnel.
J’ai longtemps douté que les TPE et PME
faisaient partie de la solution.
J’ai longtemps pensé que c’était aux
politiques d’agir avant les citoyens,
longtemps cru que
c’étaient les grandes entreprises
qui devaient changer les choses.
Mais ces doutes n’ont pas eu raison
de mes convictions et de mes engagements.
Avoir suivi mon cœur,
avoir presque tout changé
à mon mode de vie,
avoir créé une société de conseil
en RSE en période de COVID,
devrait être la plus belle preuve
qu’en RSE, en développement durable,
aucune personne ni aucune entreprise
n’est trop petite
pour agir pour un monde meilleur.
Merci.